how do you raise money for a movie
that's a good question
um
every project has been different have
put it together and figured it out it's
been various ways sometimes it's been
grant money from for example
um SF film does grants and they give a
lot of money away
to projects that warrant the money
so I go to SF film or try back a Film
Institute well TFI is not here anymore
but in the past I have as well as
Sundance as various labs and there's
other
festivals as well that have some type of
lab or dynamic to be able to do that but
outside of that I go to places where I
can find money
um one of the ways I raise money on a
project was that at least in Long Island
there's country clubs everywhere and in
the summer their golf tournaments and in
New Jersey too and Upstate Westchester
so
I go to events where there's people that
have
um that type of money so I've gone to a
golf tournament I was at the table
getting like my salsa water with lemon
and lime as usual and this guy came up
to me and um he's like oh what do you do
what's your story and he's a very
interesting guy not in film he's kind of
like a startup guy and he's been in some
really great Ventures and made good
money and I told him like what I do and
why I was there and he's like well I
know someone that you should talk to and
that was it so I followed up with him
put me in touch with this guy and
um I set up a meeting with this guy and
I still to this day don't know if he's a
CPA
um or if he's a tax attorney I still
don't know
um and I pretty much went in and I met
with him and I told him what I do and
I'm like you know I'm assuming that he
has clientele or clients that
um have access to money that can invest
because that was always the thing I
would did I look for CPAs
or lawyers
that have a lot of clientele on that
level that have that kind of income
because they maybe need to lose money or
they need to have write-offs or or maybe
they'll be open to that Venture so he
looked at me and said I don't have
anyone like that you know and I'm like
why are we even here how did this meet
even get set up he didn't even know what
the meeting was about I didn't even know
who he was and he's like well you know I
invested in some plays and you know I've
done a movie or two and I'm like oh
you're the guy and he's like yeah so I'm
like I should be pitching you then
should I pitch them and you know it's
like all right send me all the paperwork
and everything I look at it so I
followed up with him uh and then like a
month later met up with him again this
time I came with my team at the time I
had representation I came with my
manager and you know the let him know
that we're like legit we're not going to
take the money and run to Aruba and he
was like okay all right
um you know send me more paperwork and
let me think about it sent the paperwork
again followed up with him a month later
like he said he didn't read it you know
he hasn't looked at he hasn't had the
time he's very busy I get it especially
dealing with people's taxes or if he's a
tax attorney whatever
um and then ultimately I went in that
third time just one-on-one with him and
pitched him
and he cut me to check just like that so
you know does it always happen like that
no you know
um and even till this day you know he
calls and checks in on me like hey you
know
um he wants to you know I was a member
at the Friars clubs I'd bring him there
the fires Club is a prestigious private
club in New York
um where Frank Sinatra The Rat Pack they
were all members they're the ones that
started the comedy roast so I was a
member there for many years and uh while
being there I would bring an entertain
potential financiers and um the owner of
the Minnesota Vikings is a member you
know I remember going in one night and
um I'm a curious person to ask questions
and I saw that one of the rooms that's
never really like booked up for private
events was closed and it was our
Thursday night Cabaret night and I asked
like one of the waiters that worked
there like what's going on why is the
room closed oh this guy's celebrating
you know he sold his company I'm like oh
that's cool
um you know how much did you sell his
company for sold it for uh 980 million
I'm like whoa who is this guy I need to
meet him you know and everything is
private you know in a private club so
people don't really want their business
being known so I said listen give me the
Intel I won't say your name I'll just
you know say I found out so
I waited for this thing to end and then
I approached this guy you know and I
said congratulations and he doesn't know
who the hell I am congratulating him
he's probably like I'm like yeah man you
know they call him the wolf you know
like he was slick this guy you know he's
like I became a billionaire you know
selling his company and he was well off
before he sold the company so you know
I'm congratulating him and telling him
how proud I am of him and it's amazing
and you know I know he probably had this
whole story and he said like what the
hell is this guy talking about who is he
you know
um and then we just stayed in touch you
know and I'd see him at various events
once in a blue
um and he always just told me like you
know like when the time is right if
there was something that made sense uh
to approach him you know I never did
approach him there wasn't something I
felt because I don't I feel that you
have one shot
sometimes especially with a billionaire
so I want to make sure it's something
that's a no-brainer It lines up I mean
this guy is screaming A-list you know so
the project is not going to be something
with an ensembled cast of working actors
in television this is probably going to
be with Brad Pitt you know like then
he's going to pay attention he's that
kind of guy you know so uh being in a
private club has helped a lot you know
like the the Friars Club I've met so
many you know financiers or potential
financiers and people introduce me you
know or it doesn't even have to be the
Friars Club it could be Soul house or
you know or Norwood which is another
private club on 14th Street in Manhattan
or the core club which is super
expensive I think it's like 50 Grand to
apply for the application and then 15
000 every year
um so you know with the Friars Club it
was it was expensive not as expensive as
a court Club
um but that was one way I found a lot of
you know potential financiers
um and people that are willing dealing
that like entertainment because it's an
entertainment club
um and then going to Polo matches you
know to have a horse is it's not like in
the early back in the day where everyone
had a horse you know and it was cheap
and having a car was expensive it's the
other way around now if you have a horse
have a good horse
a horse that does polos at least like a
million dollars or something to feed it
right to maintain it you know have a
ranch it could run around so I go to
Bethpage Polo it's in Long Island and
they also do in the Hamptons in Long
Island too and I go to these matches and
I'll just go and I look at the calendar
sometimes they have an event with
Ferrari all right if they can afford a
Ferrari they have a horse they can
definitely cut a check so I go in and
you know I just start talking to these
people I introduce them and the thing is
that most of these people they started
from something or maybe they were born
into a family with money you know but
they respect the hustle so you know
straight to the point make sure my eyes
are dotted tease across who I am why I'm
there and like oh you know that's so
interesting and you know it can add it
to my collection or something so
um did I successfully close any
investors at Polo matches no but I did
build a Rolodex of people you know that
were open and interested and the things
that you need one yes you don't need you
know a bunch of yeses that's all you
need so and and one door may open up to
another door you know
um
I made a promise to myself to go to Art
basil every year a cashing director I
work with was in with these guys from
RBC the Royal Bank of Canada I went to
some really boring event that they threw
together at the Harvard Club in
Manhattan and it was very stuffy you
know Wall Street types and you know I
actually fell asleep a couple of times
you know it was like a nine hour intense
day talking about things that you know I
felt they were talking hieroglyphics and
reciprocals and I just didn't understand
you know I understood some of it but I
couldn't weigh in but at the end of the
day I became friendly with the guys from
RBC they kept talking about art baths
I'm like what is this art basil thing I
don't even know what it is and I felt a
little embarrassed because everyone else
knew and there were a lot of people in
the art world that were there or
collectors so the RBC guy said we're
going to Art battles with the end of the
year you know this was maybe in this
late spring or summer so I said hey I
want to come and they said okay great
we'd love to have you down there you
just got to make your way down there so
uh before I Dazzle you know I
reconnected with RBC guys and I stayed
in touch with them throughout you know
developed a relationship with one of the
financial uh advisors over there
um and I'd invited him to the Friars
Club and he loved it and geeked out
um and I was looking for ways to help
him as well so on a one-way street it's
give and take give and take it wasn't
hey just get me to Art basil it's like
how can I help your business or clients
you know and he appreciated that because
most people don't ask that you know
so I went down to Art basil and uh I
went to the first night um they threw
this event at the Versace Mansion uh in
Miami and it was just incredible it was
spectacular I mean they were it got so
busy they were turning away billionaires
at the door that's how crazy it was and
from that point on I'm like I need to be
there not just I need to be there I need
to go down there with these guys because
the guys that are coming with them are
ball players or ex-ball players you know
clients that have you know Fu money you
know and really Deep Pockets hedge funds
Venture capitalists people with billion
dollar funds and maybe they're not the
right person to fund it you know but
they know someone that potentially can
so I made it a point to go to Art basil
every year except for the year of the
pandemic
um because it didn't happen
um and I've developed you know like a
investor like list and people that are
interested
um and the reality of it is that because
I've been to so many of these events I
used to have a database with all the
investors listed
you know this is a hard lesson learned
uh one of my interns had shared it
through his personal email and I sort of
loaded it to our transferred it to my
Google account but um I think his
account deleted and then I lost the
whole spreadsheet so I've I've told
myself one of these days I'm going to
build the investor spreadsheet again but
I just haven't had a chance to go
through it but the reality of it is that
I have like a Rolodex of investors and
I've forgotten their mandates because
they all have different things like you
know come to me if a project needs
finishing money or come to me when the
project is earlier on or come to me if
it's like a huge star or come to me if
it's like a million dollar movie or a 20
million dollar movie so going to all
these events along the way I've built
you know like a Rolodex of people I can
go to or and the reality of it like I
said same thing with actors you hot you
know you hire them ask them about their
friends you get one investor you get
their friends and I've done that
multiple times when I do a project like
do you have friends and their friends
come in and put money in you know
um so that's how I found private Equity
you know just going to maybe like a
dentist convention I used to be the way
that people always said is finding
investors go to dentists and doctors you
know one of my dear friends that's what
he does all his investors are dentists
and doctors he goes to these doctor
convention centers and he meets them um
so I haven't quite done that
um I will if I have to but I've gone to
other convention centers I was at this
big thing actually here in La it was
like a a cell phone convention and
um and it was the last day I was there
um and I and I met this guy he was a guy
from the Middle East that was between
Miami and the UAE and I told him what I
did and he was like wow that's
interesting I've always wanted to get
into the movie business and monetize my
money so then he approached me about
investing I had gone down to Miami a
couple times to meet with him and you
know his brother
um and I built this model I'm not
exercising it right now but it's
basically lasting last in first out you
know
um and lifo last in first out that's the
term and he was really interested in
this model and how it works is
you know if it's available
um if the film is set up if it's not
pair of pursue this investor could come
in last when the film gets sold they get
paid out first like if the film is
almost finished with production or it's
finished with production you know and he
really liked that model and that's what
he wanted to do
um and uh the problem is that I did find
some films that did have that but
um he wanted a quick return
uh so I couldn't guarantee a quick
return and I just told him that when I
have a project where a return can be
quick you know then I can Bridge you in
and bring you in
um but yeah it was just right place
right time sharing that story with this
individual
um but now when I build out projects I'm
also thinking about you know what
production company or what
um uh you know maybe distributor you
know I could maybe partner up with
Finance it and release it that's been
you know my my strategy now going
forward and I'm not going to do that on
every movie
um but I was just in the UK for example
and I met with this writer director and
he just did this movie I did really well
he's on a series now and I met with two
financiers while I was out in the UK
that I met at can
um well one of them I met a can the
other one I met
um virtually but they go to can all the
time and um the first group I met with
they'd already know me they liked my
work we want to find something together
they were familiar with the director I
was going to meet with and they want to
work with him too the second group I met
with they have three companies one is a
sales company that helps find financing
the other one finances against debt
meaning tax credits or you know any type
of debt and the third one is more of an
equity you know company so I'd mentioned
this filmmaker they were very familiar
with them and they want to work with me
too so going into that meeting I already
liked the director like his work well I
don't know if I like him yet I know I
like what I've read so far so when I met
with him we spent two or three hours and
really bonded together and I told them
about the groups I met with and that
they know him and he's like I know them
too and that's great so now potentially
we have financing the finance whatever
we want to do together
um and then he told me about the two
groups that financed his last shown and
he told me about an overall deal that he
has
um you know he told me to speak with his
agent to clarify it his agent had
introduced us
um so ultimately we don't have a project
yet but I like him he's cuban-american
from Miami
um I'm haitian-american you know I lived
in Miami for a little bit we have that
connection we like each other like each
other's work you know he watched my film
the same day
um and he's like I wanna I love what you
did I don't know how you created it I
want to work with you and
um and I liked his work so now we
ultimately
um are going to find something to work
on together we figured out the financing
and we just have to figure out the
distribution that works properly you
know with this
um so that's one you know example of me
figuring out the financing before we
even shoot you know
um can I ask you something real quick
sorry what does it mean to respect the
hustle you said with some of these
individuals these these high net worth
individuals you'll meet them and they
respect the hustle what is that mean
most people over promise them to deliver
you know so I'll give you a perfect
example of where it completely flipped
um
I went to Sonoma Film Festival I want to
say it was maybe 2017 first time I had
the film that I did with Miss Shady's
rule there and um how Sonoma works is
that if you have a feature at least back
then I don't know how it is now if you
have a feature they put you up in a
hotel if you have a short then they pair
you up with a housemate or something
like a family that wants to go to the
festival and this is their way of
volunteering and the homes in Sonoma are
very nice so
um I paired up with this family that was
really amazing and they stayed in touch
with me and I stayed in touch with them
after and what ended up happening is
that uh the the woman of the household
had sent me a text one day about this
guy named Gary Nelson and um I opened up
uh this link read about him and he has
an HR company that's been very
successful and he wanted to get involved
in film he went to finance movies and
um he wanted to make the kind of films
that I was making and he had some other
other things that he wanted to add and
he really loved Sonoma and his you know
like his town in his City and
um and humankind so she didn't tell me
to contact him she was just sharing
found it interesting I took it as like I
need to call this guy so I found his HR
number called asked to speak to him
asked who I am I said I'm a filmmaker I
read this article I want to work with
Gary Nelson oh okay all right well um
you're not going to get his number I'll
give you his email you can email him and
if he wants to engage
you know he'll he'll engage with you
so right after I wrote a very detailed
email sharing about my experience in
Sonoma I love Sonoma and that um I read
about his mandate and how I'm making the
type of films that he wants to finance
and that I'd love to work with him you
know and he emailed me back within five
minutes sent me his number we jumped on
a call and I told him you know
um I'm gonna come out there one day and
meet with you and shake your hand so you
know I'm serious and I want to work with
you and you said okay all right great
you know he probably hears it all the
time so what had happened was that I
think I told you after Sundance I go to
La for about a month and that's what
happened the following year I went to LA
um and the bay is only a 45 minute plane
ride you know from LA from LAX so I
booked a one-way
um up there I called Gary I said Gary
guess what I'm coming to Sonoma to meet
you and he was like what like yeah so I
I took a sprinter bus and and this
stupid Mark Twain quote I kept hearing
because this was um was it was it in the
summer no no it wasn't in the summer
that happened another time when I went
to see Gary but Mark Twain has this
thing where he says the coldest winter I
ever had was a a summer in San Francisco
and I'd gone in a T-shirt and I was like
freezing cold and know that it was cold
in San Francisco that time of the year
so anyway I jumped on a sprinter bus it
takes about an hour to get into Sonoma
County
got into Sonoma County and then I jumped
in a 45 minute Uber and drove to Gary
met him
how did you get here you have no car oh
I took Uber and then he told me by the
way I am an investor in Lyft if you
don't mind you know take lifts so now
usually I take Lyft if I'm in the US if
I'm outside of the Country lift doesn't
exist I take an Uber
um and then
um
I basically did exactly what I told Gary
I was going to do you know like he saw
that I took a plane I took a bus took a
uber just to sit down with him I didn't
ask for anything and
um he bought me breakfast it was very
nice of him and uh we had a really good
meeting we spent like almost two hours
together and it went from me pitching
him to him telling me about the projects
that he's wanting to make and do I want
to be a part of it and there was a
project that he wanted to tell
um and I got on it right away it was a
lot of prolific singer
um uh from the 70s or 80s and um I was
saying like Gary we need to move on a
quick Gary doesn't move his that move as
fast as I do but what ended up happening
was that there was an announcement in
the trades that the story was snatched
up and
it didn't happen so uh because of that
but um so meeting the hustle is you know
I mean this is I'm not saying that this
is the only way to do it I mean this is
probably you know I uh I feel like I
um
uh I I over delivered and under-promised
that's what I did you know in terms of
that you know like granted I said that's
what I would do but most people aren't
going to do that you know like if it's
someone that's serious NFL next flight
out I will go anywhere in the world Abu
Dhabi Dubai you know if I have to learn
a couple of words you know whatever I
need to do I'll go there you know it has
to be someone very serious and multiple
comments I'm not going to just go
because it's a big investment in time
and money but I want people to treat me
very serious and know that I'm no joke I
expect them to cut a check if I'm going
to do all of that if it fits within what
they would you know their mandate or
whatever how they invest I'll make sure
that I Tee It Up to make sure that
everything is
um
in top T shape um and that's what I mean
like meet the hustle because most people
aren't going to do that you know it's
exceptional or rare so they know that I
am going to take care of their asset you
know I'm not going to take their money
and run around the world and just live
my life I'm going to take their money
and do my best to get them a return
um at least break even and communicate
with them and let them know and if I
mess up let them know too you know
because there's no guarantees in this
business there's things can you know
there's a acts of nature that could
affect things
what would make a doctor dentist lawyer
someone who's a CPA invest in an
independent film
a lot of time is Vanity you know like oh
cool my name is on
this project you know like I'm an
executive producer you know most of the
time when they're doing that there's
this rumor you know it's kind of true is
that even though these guys are
brilliant they're not good with their
money they put their money into stupid
things so a lot of times at least a
doctor you know a lawyer will be a
little bit smarter
um but doctors and dentists specifically
they do it all the time they buy things
that they don't need you know
um so that's why they're a great you
know Target in terms of that
um and why they've invested so many
times lawyers
um more or less maybe they'll bring in a
client or maybe they'll put in
um but same kind of deal like I remember
being at Sundance and I went to this
party and I don't think anything happens
by accident if I ended up at this party
didn't know much about it and um the
party or event most of the people there
were all investors had no idea I just
went and the young lady I spoke with
majority of the time see what was a
lawyer that invest in film and she
represents 50 people that invest so you
know again they have links to it or you
know
um
a lot of times maybe they want to help
save change the world or they want to do
some type of impact
yeah or or it's just exciting to go to a
screening go to a festival maybe their
work is so you know cut and dry or
something that's not as I know it seems
sexy and fun to be a part of filming
it's a lot sometimes what they'll do is
that they'll bring a um their client to
set oh you know like look I invest in
movies that's what I do it's you know
it's vanity like oh wow you know so
sometimes it's that you know so it's a
multiple
bit of things